mais il ya 80 ans sa mort c'est l'un des
pires conflits de l'histoire de
l'humanité la seconde guerre mondiale
était déclenché un 1er septembre 1939 et
il ya des chefs d'état d'une quarantaine
de pays qui sont réunis en pologne
aujourd'hui pour souligner cet
anniversaire en pologne rémy parce que
justement c'est dans ce pays là que tout
a commencé
exactement il faut se transporter à
l'époque c'est là que les forces
allemandes ont commencé à bombarder avec
entre autres un bateau qui avaient
bombardé la ville de danger il y avait
une installation militaire là à 4h45 les
matins au même moment plusieurs troupes
de l'allemagne nazie ont traversé la
frontière en pologne et ont attaqué et
moins d'un mois plus tard et bien le
pays tomber aux mains des soviets et de
l'allemagne nazie qui l'avait attaqué
des deux côtés et c'était le début de
cette guerre c'est pas le premier
c'était le premier pays à tomber mais ce
n'était pas le dernier et aujourd'hui eh
bien on est en pologne aussi les chefs
qui se sont réunis à 4h40 le matin vous
voyez c'était très tôt ce matin au
monument qui souligne cet endroit où a
eu lieu la première bataille d'après de
dantzig est il si vous voyez ces images
aux bombardements projetées sur le mur
nous sommes dans la première ville qui a
été bombardé une des premières en fait
oui l'one en pologne aussi ou ont une
autre cérémonie a eu lieu est finalement
tous se sont réunis à varsovie pour une
cérémonie où le vice président américain
mike pence était présent et de remplacer
le président resté aux états unis en
raison de l'ouragan
dorian qui sans qu'ils s'en vient dont
la pologne et première donc à subir
cette guerre mais l'un des pays aussi
les plus frappés par cette guerre là oui
exactement il ya un cinquième de la
population de la pologne qui a perdu la
vie au cours de cette guerre essayez
particulièrement s'était partiellement
difficile pour la population jeu
il y avait trois millions de personnes
qui vivaient 3 millions de juifs et
seulement 300 milles ont survécu à la
guerre la guerre elle-même a fait un
million de morts du côté militaire et 40
millions du côté civil ça démontre
l'intensité de cette guerre le canada a
participé bien sûr et il y avait plus
d'un million de soldats du canada et de
terre-neuve et 44000 ont perdu la vie au
cours du conflit
merci beaucoup rémy